i want to kick things off by talking
about this this theme
of embracing your differences i want to
know for the two of you
what are some of the qualities that you
have that you maybe felt like
different or maybe even insecure about
but ultimately
you wound up embracing it and making it
like your superpower
there was one point in my life where i
was feeling a little bit insecure about
my hair
i know that sounds crazy now but um it
was just because i was the only kid in
my class that had curly hair a lot of
people would call it poofy and it was
big
and so it got the better of me but i
remember going home with
um to my parents one day and they gave
me this
powerful pep talk and they just said you
know it's something it's what makes you
you it's the strength of yours it's
unique you know and i learned to accept
it as a
as that that's what makes me me and it's
the strength of mine it really is
yes and you are so beautiful for the
record so are you sienna what what was
maybe your insecurity and how did you
get through it
i was i'm a very goofy person and and so
i you know i can come across very
awkward sometimes
but i think being around people who
truly get you and
and and love you for who you are um and
of course like you have to have that
mentally for yourself as well
and loving yourself that was always so
hard because
i had to find my people and the people
who made me feel loved and
learning to accept that like embrace it
yourself and find people around you who
love and support you
the movie ends totally set up perfectly
for
a sequel
do you guys know is there a sequel
happening have there been conversations
i honestly have i honestly have no idea
i'm in the same boat as you guys
um but i but i didn't notice that and i
can't i can't
if there is i i'm very excited for
everyone to see it
what do you think the next chapter of
nori and reyna would look like in a part
two
great question i mean they both went
through some pretty
um adventurous things and and definitely
changed a lot
so i think something that's going to be
super special to see is
their journey like in the second movie
and how they're going to interact with
each other
and their place in the school i mean
they're there for six years so
um one year done and and what's gonna
happen when nori
does accept who she is and everybody
around her doesn't accept who she is and
and reyna what's that what that what
that's gonna look like and
um the support around her a question
that i have because i did
sense a little bit of um romantic
friction between nori and andreas do you
think we're gonna get more
romance in movies moving forward oh
i i noticed that i i don't know i i
honestly have no idea andres and
nori are still very young uh they make
it kind of where it's like the comedian
way of
being a little bit more like oh you know
this but um
i i think it was so much fun interacting
with him because we
we were laughing through the whole
entire thing we were just like we can't
believe it we were we were so
it was just like a whole like um you
know we were just laughing about it and
it was just so amazing so
i don't know okay well i do have my
fingers crossed that we might get a
musical
number is that something that you guys
would want to do or have talked about
so we have some very very exciting music
things um in the works of the whole cast
that i can't wait for everyone to see
everything everything's magic
ladies you guys are all so talented i
mean we got to see was that actually
kyle singing
there's a hilarious story but um behind
that so
when we were doing the table read where
we all get to like
pretty much re-enact the movie um uh in
all the cast is there
uh kyle he actually sung it in the same
room
and he sounds so amazing but um when
he's actually seen in the movie it's
actually somewhat it's someone else
singing for him
got it okay fingers crossed for a
musical number
i just want to know i think this movie
is going to be big i think it's going to
be like high school musical big like
descendants big
are the two of you prepared for that
huge level of fame
being a part of a movie that's that's so
special and and
has so many messages like i'm so
grateful that um
we get to represent um
along with the cast and crew i mean like
represent a movie that
promotes individuality and um friendship
yeah exactly how sienna said you know
i'm so glad we get to be a part of this
amazing movie that you know has so many
amazing and powerful messages behind it
um and how all of us really get to um
i think really get to walk in air
responsibility instead of entitlement as
role models my last question what was it
like filming your disney channel juan
promo
when i found out that we were gonna do
that i instantly
freaked out i had no i i was feeling so
many crazy emotions
i grew up on that and i was like i want
to do that one day you know everyone
tries to get a stick and just reenact it
and to be able to do that it was just
such a dream come true and i really hope
it does show other people that you know
if you put hard work in it will pay off